[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JT des
territoires tout de suite voici les
titres de l'actualité il est l'une des
plus grandes stars de cinéma français
Alain Delon a décidé de se mobiliser
pour soutenir l'Ukraine l'acteur vient
de terminer l'enregistrement d'une
émission spéciale en soutien au pays
Christophe Rigaud a pu le suivre lors de
sa venue à Paris ce sont des images
exclusives du Grand JT des territoires
le sport à sec à cause de la sécheresse
à Brest 4 des 5 piscines municipales
sont fermées du fait des restrictions
d'eau une situation qui n'est pas sans
incidence sur les clubs locaux reportage
de TBO la chaîne du groupe Le Télégramme
en Bretagne à suivre dans quelques
instants
des modèles uniques les voitures
matisses ont marqué l'histoire
automobile du début du XXème siècle
aujourd'hui l'âme du constructeur
perdure grâce à de passionnés qui comme
vous le verrez et comme nous le montrera
Canal 32 sont vraiment des fanatiques de
l'automobile et puis enfin le journal la
rédaction de via télé pas aisée nous
fera découvrir l'île de beauté depuis
les airs grâce à un bateau volant et oui
image splendide garantie
une star internationale au service d'un
pays héroïque l'acteur iconique Alain
Delon a décidé de revenir sur le devant
de la scène médiatique pour soutenir
l'Ukraine et ses habitants attaqués par
la Russie il y a presque 7 mois
désormais l'emblématique acteur vient
notamment de terminer l'enregistrement
d'une émission spéciale en l'honneur de
l'un des plus grands poètes Ukrainiens
ta race stevensko Christophe Rigaud a
suivi Alain Delon lors de sa venue à
Paris s'est exclusif pour le grand JT
des territoires regardez
Alain Delon est de retour et pour cent
come-back l'acteur a décidé de se
mobiliser aux côtés de l'Ukraine un
engagement politique fort qui l'a voulu
partager avec l'ambassadeur du crâne en
France tout pour l'Ukraine alors pour
soutenir l'Ukraine et défendre son
indépendance face à l'invasion russe
Alain Delon a repris son costume
d'acteur en enregistrant des textes du
plus grand pot es ukrainien ta race
quand je serai mort
mettez-moi dans le théâtre qui sert de
tombe au milieu de la pleine immense
dans mon Ukraine bien-aimée
pour que je vois les gens sans fin le
série abrupte et que j'entends de
mugir lorsque le Nièvre emportera vers
la mer bleue loin de l'Ukraine le sang
ennemi
la star française est aussi connue à
Paris kakiev alors son soutien a
beaucoup touché l'ambassade de ukrainien
en France le diplomate a même invité
Alain Delon au centre culturel ukrainien
de Paris 22 avenue de Messine une
adresse que connait bien l'acteur pour
avoir été son ancien hôtel particulier
où il a vécu avec Romy Schneider le
centre culturel a même décidé de
consacrer à la star une exposition qui
retrace toute sa vie et son œuvre
une occasion pour Alain Delon de
renouveler sa solidarité avec le peuple
ukrainien ce qu'on a fait à lui créer ce
qu'on fait à l'Ukraine ma profondément
attristé toucher c'est pour ça que je me
bats pour voilà
un soutien qui compte pour l'ambassadeur
du crâne à Paris cette soutien elle est
très important pour nous pour chaque
couple pour chacun de nous pour le
crayon pour chaque soldat sur la ligne
de front pour chaque réfugié qui
viennent ici en France en Europe
c'est ce geste de soutien de parc de
mission de Lens ça va être très
important pour les éditions Seghers qui
viennent de publier notre âme ne peut
pas mourir de ta race tchétchenko la
contribution d'Alain Delon est
importante une voix comme Alain Delon
qui porte les vers de tachenko scène
résonance européenne c'est une résonance
mondiale et encore une fois
c'est une résonance
c'est l'homme qui a été en prison en
Russie qui a été persécuté par le
pouvoir politique russe qui incarne
l'âme nationale ukrainienne
les enregistrements d'Alain Delon feront
l'objet d'émission diffusé sur TV5 Monde
et les chaînes du groupe Canal+ avec
pour thématique le soutien à l'Ukraine
mais aussi une ode à la liberté les
initiales de la liberté sont celles de
la République
des femmes des hommes et de tout ce qui
a vu
liberté capitale toute nation
[Musique]
sur l'espoir sans souvenir j'écris ton
nom et par le pouvoir d'un mot je
recommence ma vie je suis pour te
connaître pour se nommer
liberté
[Musique]
l'émission spéciale d'Alain Delon et son
soutien à l'Ukraine sera diffusé d'ici
la fin du mois de septembre sur les
chaînes du groupe Canal+ et sur TV5
Monde dans 200 pays et en 24 langues la
guerre en Ukraine qui est aussi au cœur
du festival Visa pour l'Image dédiée aux
photos journalistes à Perpignan à
l'occasion de cette 34e édition les
visiteurs ont pu notamment découvrir des
clichés de journalistes ayant couvert le
conflit depuis février dernier vous en
découvrez quelques-uns à l'écran grâce à
ces images de nos partenaires sur place
de via Occitanie du groupe La Dépêche
le conflit à l'est de l'Europe qui n'est
pas vous le savez sans conséquence
énergétique gaz électricité fuel les
prix se sont envolés depuis plusieurs
semaines le chauffage au bois n'échappe
pas à cette tendance plus 35% pour les
poils ou les chaudières précisions et
explications avec ce reportage dans deux
entreprises signées Thierry Lasson pour
vos jeter les lésions regardez
ça c'est devenu de l'heure et le prix a
plus que doublé à ce jour en magasin on
est passé 345 euros à 850 euros au genre
d'aujourd'hui 850 euros la tonne et 13
euros le sac de 15 kg la flambée des
prix de l'énergie n'épargne pas le
pellet comme en témoigne cette
installateur de chaudière et poêle à
granulés basés à Granges de l'or qui
vient de Belgique et dont le coût ne
cessé d'augmenter ces derniers mois en
cause notamment un ralentissement de la
production mondiale et puis autre
phénomènes sur stockage et pas seulement
de la part des particuliers cette
pénurie était accentuée par certains on
va dire fabricants ou fournisseurs plus
exactement des gros qui aujourd'hui
ont beaucoup de granulés on stocke mais
nous les vendent plus depuis mars avril
voilà en fait c'est de la spéculation
oui c'est exactement la spéculation avec
un grand S les chaudières et poêles à
granulés ont également vu leur prix
exploser plus 35%
selon l'entrepreneur toujours on a déjà
des clients qui souhaitent entre
guillemets annuler leur commande ou
retarder leur commande de roulant leur
installation de chaudière et du poêle à
granulés même constat du côté de Golbey
dans cette autre entreprise un sac de 15
kilos actuellement ça coûte 11 euros
grosso modo pour le mois de septembre on
part palette on a un tarif un peu
dégressif mais on est à 690 euros la
tonne et l'année dernière oui on était
dans les 300 330 euros la tonne ici on
fabrique du granulé vosgien qui vient
compléter ses stocks venus également de
Belgique et l'on sent bien le recul du
particulier devant cette montée des prix
on voit bien qu'il y a des personnes qui
qui réduisent leur approvisionnement qui
vont pas réussir à passer l'hiver parce
qu'ils ont fait un petit
approvisionnement de deux tonnes qui
leur suffira pas les chiffres d'affaires
de nos deux entreprises ne sont pas pour
l'heure impactés mais des inquiétudes de
se font jour pour l'avenir d'autant que
le prix du bois et lui aussi à la
oui voilà et en plus du coup de
l'énergie la France est aussi concernée
par une pénurie d'eau dans certains
territoires et restrictions prises
localement interdisent notamment les
collectivités de remplir leur piscine
municipale conséquence directe la
pratique des sports aquatiques devient
presque impossible dans certaines
régions exemple à Brest ou 80% des
piscines sont fermées avec ce reportage
de Frédéric lorenzan pour TVO la chaîne
du couple télégramme sur place
ces agents d'entretien peuvent inspecter
le carrelage de la piscine Saint-Marc de
Brest à pied sec quatre des cinq bassins
Brestois sont vides et ceux depuis fin
juin une obligation de vidange sanitaire
annuelle problème les restrictions d'eau
liées à la sécheresse interdisent
désormais à la ville de remplir les
piscines nous avons des obligations
annuelles de vidange que l'on respecte
et habituellement on n'avons pas ces
conditions exceptionnelles climatiques
donc nous avions trois piscines qui qui
sont vidangés qui ont été vidangés cet
été à cette crise hydrique s'ajoute des
travaux de la piscine de Recouvrance qui
ont pris deux mois de retard en raison
de problèmes d'approvisionnement dans
ces conditions la ville a suspendu les
inscriptions et définie des priorités la
première est de favoriser au maximum le
savoir nager pour les plus jeunes
puisqu'on sort de deux années de
pandémie ou il y a eu un gros impact sur
l'apprentissage des enfants va ouvrir la
piscine Foch au grand public le week-end
de 10h à 17h pour les nageurs sportifs
privés de leur bassin de 50 mètres
actuellement en travaux l'accès
prioritaire à la piscine Foch est une
bonne chose mais il ne faut pas que la
crise dure alors pour les athlètes on a
la chance de que la mairie nous mette à
disposition la piscine Foch a des
créneaux qui sont normalement ouverts au
public il faut c'est qu'on arrive à
avoir une anticipation faut pas qu'au
mois de décembre on se retrouve à
nouveau dans la panade avec pas de
solution parce que nous au mois de
décembre on a déjà des championnats de
France élite déjà en déficit depuis si
avant la crise l'épisode de sécheresse
démontre que Brest manque cruellement de
bassin
des piscines au terrain de rugby le
monde de l'Ovalie et lui aussi touché
par la sécheresse les pelouses en
particulier rendent compliqué les
plaquages et autres contacts avec un sol
devenu dur comme du béton démonstration
dans la Somme avec un sujet de Jérémie
Houbron pour jouer au TV la chaîne de la
Voix du Nord regarde
donc on a réduit la largeur il faut être
beaucoup plus efficace si vous voulez
pas tomber sur ce sol il faut mettre de
la vitesse cela ressemble à un
entraînement de rugby normal sur une
pelouse normale mais la poussière
soulevée à chaque pas des joueurs et
l'absence d'herbe par endroits ne trompe
pas ici aussi la sécheresse a fait son
œuvre c'est dur dur dur il faut que la
pluie arrive vachement aussi mal un peu
partout là avec le sol qui est dur c'est
un difficile retour sur le terrain pour
ses joueurs du club de rugby de
Flesselles la saison est sur le point de
reprendre mais l'absence de pluie cet
été a rendu le sol aussi dur que du
béton craignant les blessures certains
préfèrent même les baskets au crampons
quand on plaque on tombe sur un sol très
dur on se fait mal à des endroits bidons
de le genou les coudes mais c'est des
endroits sensibles où il y a pas trop de
peau pas de muscles du coup
on se fait mal facilement quoi ici comme
dans beaucoup d'autres clubs amateurs
pas question d'iriguer la pelouse et
aucune solution de repli pas le choix
pour assurer la préparation des joueurs
et limiter les risques de blessure il a
fallu adapter les plannings on devait
tout l'été répéter des gestes techniques
de base dans le placage et on les a
répété sur du matériel ou en sans
terminer son action pour pas que nos
joueurs aillent au sol bref partez
serrer les dents et attendre la pluie
annoncée en milieu de semaine c'est peu
mais c'est tout ce qu'il reste au joueur
du rugby olympique de Flesselles qui
joueront ici leur premier match amical
face à Senlis ce samedi
voilà et on referme cette page consacrée
au sport avec un clin d'oeil au club de
rugby de Limoges lu sale comme on
l'appelle là-bas qui vient d'accéder à
la quatrième division nationale une
montée qui n'empêche pas le club d'être
ambitieux et d'espérer pourquoi pas de
monter encore d'un échelon à la fin de
la saison bien sûr on leur souhaite
évidemment bonne chance dans leur
conquête sportive direction la Gironde à
présent dans cette édition où les
vendanges battent actuellement leur
plein et si l'on sait déjà que ce
millésime s'annonce comme l'un des plus
précoces du fait des conditions
climatiques les professionnels
découvrent aussi que les récoltes sont
en baisse cette année une mauvaise
nouvelle supplémentaire pour la filière
illustration avec la cave de Rosan et ce
reportage de Télé 7 la chaîne du groupe
sud-ouest
c'est quasiment la fin de la récolte des
raisins blancs pour la cave coopérative
de rose si leurs qualités sanitaire
régustatives semble au rendez-vous la
quantité fait défaut elle laisse même un
goût amer dans la bouche des vignerons
de cette cave coopérative les volumes de
vin blanc produit en 2022 sont de
25% par rapport au rendement maximum
autorisé dans les appellations de blanc
sec Girondins pire avec le gel et la
grêle 2021 avait été un tout petit
millésime en quantité 2022 est encore en
retrait de 10% par rapport à l'an
dernier ce qui pose déjà des problèmes
commerciaux pour le directeur général
des caves de rose on arrive
malheureusement au bout des stocks en
blanc on a beaucoup de demandes et là
malheureusement on va pas pouvoir
arriver à alimenter tous les marchés
donc il va falloir faire des choix et
c'est frustrant parce que on en aurait
la vente à de bon prix et on n'aura pas
la récolte quoi depuis 4 ou 5 ans les
caves de Rosan constatent un regain
d'appétence pour les vins blancs qu'ils
soient pétillant sec ou moelleux
notamment auprès des consommateurs ces
mains blancs sont de plus en plus
demandés pour le directeur de la cave de
Rosan une hausse des prix est donc
quasiment inévitable cette année c'est
déjà le cas pour les mises en marché
entre professionnels du secteur ouais
l'augmentation c'est un petit peu
difficile à dire jusqu'à quel niveau
elle va être répercutée
et jusqu'à quel niveau est sensible pour
le consommateur mais bon moi j'imagine
que ça va être de l'ordre de 5 à 10%
les caves de rosanes ont d'ailleurs
commencé la récolte elle devrait se
terminer autour du 23 septembre
le retour était évidemment très attendu
après la pandémie les croisièresistes
foules de nouveau le sol de la
Martinique le temps d'une escale une
bonne nouvelle bien sûr pour l'ensemble
de l'économie locale comme a pu le
constater Diana François Eudoxie pour la
chaîne via ATV en Martinique le
mastodonte de 307 m de long à garer sa
carcasse à la Pointe Simon malgré un
temps plus vieux les quadiristes sont
enthousiastes il compte bien profiter de
leur escale à Fort-de-France comme ce
couple venant des États-Unis le paysage
est vraiment magnifique dans le
classement des îles Caraïbes je la
placerai dans le top 3 les 2370
passagers à bord sont attendus avec
impatience par les commerçants du port
après deux ans sans croisière ils
espèrent relancer leur activité j'ai
vend des magnets c'est quelque chose que
les gens aiment beaucoup et puis ça
prend pas beaucoup de place et puis
aussi des casquettes
voilà il y a des casquettes oui ça va
oui oui j'ai déjà fait des gentils après
les boutiques vient le moment de se
restaurer pour notre couple d'américains
un accueil spécial a été réservé pour ce
groupe de 80 croisésistes dans ce
restaurant du Nord la clientèle venant
des croisières représentait près de 50%
du chiffre d'affaires en haute saison
c'était vraiment très important pour
nous de leur faire sentir qu'ils étaient
attendus justement devront de touristes
chez nous c'est très important mais
c'est à côté le côté financier mais il y
a aussi le côté
le côté contact une immersion culturelle
qui ravie Victor est Annie
le restaurant est vraiment magnifique
c'est un restaurant cosy nous avons aimé
la musique nous avons aimé le punch le
jus d'ananas jusqu'ici le repas était
délicieux il reste encore quelques
heures pour en profiter ensuite ce sera
cap sur 5 kit nevisses pour les
passagers du Célébrity Equinox la
prochaine escale de bateau de croisière
en Martinique aura lieu le 7 octobre
tout à fait autre chose dans cette
édition découvrons à présent une drôle
de tendance celle des cercueils en
carton personnalisables oui vous avez
bien entendu aussi étonnant que cela
puisse paraître ils sont proposés à la
vente depuis quelques années en Moselle
plus écolo et moins cher c'est cercueil
sont le symbole d'une filière qui se met
au vert au portage de Ghislain
schumarquer pour Moselle
lorsque l'on pousse les portes de ces
pompes funèbres retrouve les
traditionnels plaques et fleurs mais
c'est cercueils sur le thème de l'Égypte
ou des animaux des notes du reste de la
boutique cette personnalisation insolite
est possible car c'est cercueils sont
entièrement fabriqués en carton qui a
été recyclé qui est fait dans le Grand
Est à savoir que ça c'est réalisé en
Alsace c'est une deuxième vie qu'on peut
donner à un carton des cercueils
écologiques donc qui peuvent être
enterrés ou incinérés mais ce n'est pas
leur seul atout puisque ces modèles sont
aussi une option moins coûteuse pour les
familles des défunts les prix varient
entre 350 euros et un peu plus de 1000
euros en fonction des différentes gammes
quand on a vraiment un cercueil le plus
cher c'est à dire hyper personnalisé
on est vraiment dans une gamme moyenne
basse dans le département d'autres
initiatives peuvent surprendre notamment
à kédange sur canner ici l'espace
commence à manquer dans le cimetière au
lieu de l'agrandir la commune a misé sur
un futur colombarium forestier il n'y
aura plus de caveaux de monuments mais
il y aura uniquement des arbres et les
personnes qui seront incinérés pourront
se faire inhumer au pied des arbres en
tout 64 concessions prendront place aux
pieds de ses chaînes merisiers et autres
Tilleuls à partir de novembre 2023
chacune d'entre elles sera léguée au
prix de 1000 euros comme dans le
cimetière voisin Bernard lui a déjà
réservé sa place le retraitée souhaite
avant tout éviter que sa mort ne soit
source de construction polluante je
pense qu'il faut adhérer à ce genre
d'initiative qui plus est avec ce qui se
passe à l'heure actuelle
sécheresse
climat qui change etc bon en plus vous
avez vu le cadre bucolique là c'est vous
êtes poussière vous retournez à la
poussière et ça c'est ça c'est une
vérité comme Bernard ils sont déjà une
trentaine à avoir choisi cet endroit
comme leur ultime demeure la mairie
reçoit même des appels de personnes
venant de toute la région Grand Est
il répète chante et sa vraisoudre les
problèmes les perroquets font partie des
animaux les plus intelligents de la
planète par amour pour cet oiseau un
passionné vient d'ouvrir en Haute-Savoie
l'Académie des perroquets un lieu
destiné à faire découvrir ou redécouvrir
cet animal Lucas roux s'est rendu sur
place pour la rédaction de 8 Mont-Blanc
regarder
comme Rita ils sont une trentaine
d'oiseaux à faire partie de l'académie
des perroquets cette école quelque peu
spéciale et le fruit de nombreuses
années de réflexion pour Franck avec sa
compagne il s'est enfin décidé à ouvrir
cet académie un lieu destiné à faire de
la pédagogie autour des perroquets
élevés en captivité ancien vétérinaire
franconux sa vie avec celle des
perroquets depuis plus de 20 ans son
amour pour cet animal est inconditionnel
j'ai attiré par par leur intelligence
leur beauté et
le contact ça s'est fait tout de suite
j'étais ouais attiré par par ses
volatiles entre démonstration de vol et
mini spectacle la visite proposée à
l'Académie des perroquets dure près de
deux heures un temps nécessaire pour
mettre de la magie dans les yeux du
jeune public
c'était incroyable enfin les oiseaux qui
voulaient tous c'était trop joli j'ai
beaucoup préféré le perroquet qui chante
par là du côté des parents même réaction
il semble conquis par l'expérience il
trouve que c'est vraiment deux
passionnés qui font vraiment
ressentir leur émotion plus profonde et
on voit que tout est très bien entretenu
ici donc je pense que en effet ce sont
des passionnés qui qui veulent
transmettre leur passion une passion qui
va encore plus loin Franck propose
également des stages et formation pour
les personnes souhaitant faire
l'acquisition de leur propre perroquet
ne répète pas ou ne chantent pas mes
réalise tout de même des exploits au
quotidien les filles et les garçons de
café étaient à l'honneur dans la Sarthe
plusieurs dizaines d'entre eux ont
participé à la traditionnelle course de
vitesse de la rentrée dans les rues du
Mans objectif réaliser le parcours le
plus vite possible tout en évitant de
renverser les boissons un événement
organisé dans la bonne humeur comme a pu
le constater Anthony Python pour elle
aime télécharger
top départ d'une course ancestrale une
tradition chez les filles et les garçons
de café faire une course avec un plateau
rempli de boissons un Perrier ou une
bière et un café le but arriver avec le
moins de 15 possible
alors il y a des pénalités à chaque fois
dire que pénalité si par exemple vous
arrivez avec la moitié et tout ça voilà
donc voilà c'est en ça que ça consiste
et puis ça permet aussi de regrouper un
peu notre profession de fédérer notre
profession et de se retrouver tous
ensemble
27 cafetiers participent à la course le
circuit a parcourir deux fois une boucle
entre la Place de la République et le
Vieux Mans
Erie le Venezia c'est il y a des gens de
campagne l'hôtel l'Angleterre à
Saint-Calais la petite auberge monsieur
plaît
on regrette qui est pas plus
d'établissements mais ça viendra ça
viendra dans les escaliers au pied de la
cathédrale l'ambiance rappelle le
passage des coureurs du Tour de France
des dizaines de spectateurs profitent du
spectacle
on a été cool entre nous on s’est
charrier entre nous le public était là
c'était cool ça fait plaisir en tête du
classement un serveur venu de Touraine
et grands habitués de ce type de
compétition
c'était bien difficile
à monter descendre les pavés un peu
d'herbe et gravier mais c'est une belle
course franchement c'est une belle
course je suis content de la faire dans
la région c'est le plus important pour
moi à la gagne un chèque de 300 euros
remis par le maire du Mans et une
qualification pour la finale nationale
de la cour de fille et de garçon de café
ça sera le 17 septembre à Limoges
seuls les plus âgés ont peut-être eu la
chance de conduire l'une d'entre elles
les voitures matisses ont connu leur
heure de gloire au début du 20e siècle
en France construite à Strasbourg la
mémoire de ses automobiles continue de
vivre grâce à des passionnés dans l'Aube
vous allez le voir un rassemblement
vient d'être organisé une remontée dans
le temps mécanique proposé par la
rédaction de Canal 32
grâce au club les amateurs de Matisse
cette marque de voiture française
fabriquée à Strasbourg est toujours bien
vivante c'est Émile Mathis qui a
commencé je dirais à travailler avec
etheries Bugatti et après chacun a pris
ses distances il y en a un qui a voulu
faire des voitures de sport et l'autre
qui a voulu faire des voitures
populaires la construction de l'usine
dans le quartier de la Meinau à
Strasbourg à partir de 1911 et il a
fabriqué en totalité à peu près 90 000
véhicules la Première Guerre mondiale il
est devenu le quatrième constructeur
français après Citroën Renault et
Peugeot jusqu'à la Seconde Guerre
mondiale cette industrielle a su
s'entourer d'ingénieurs pour construire
des véhicules les plus légers possible
la structure de la caisse est en bois et
elle est habillée de tôle
de toute l'Europe le club organise son
44e le rassemblement annuel les 140
participants ont prévu de découvrir le
département au volant de lune de leur
métisse samedi c'est direction où on
visite une cape de champagne et le
dimanche donc le dimanche matin c'est
notre assemblée générale c'est assez
dans les années 50 les obliger les
voitures d'avant-guerre de remettre des
clignotants
le club est devenu propriétaire de la
marque alsacienne grâce au plan elle
peut reconstruire certaines pièces
l'objectif faire en sorte que ce
patrimoine roulant puisse être vu et
connu de tous c'est classé au niveau de
la Fédération française des véhicules
d'époque donc c'est important de montrer
nos véhicules et surtout c'est très
demandé en tout une soixantaine de
voitures maid et une grande test
voici un élérotes aux boises durant 5
jours
prenons de la hauteur en cette fin de
journal pour découvrir l'île de beauté
depuis la mer et le ciel c'est
l'activité proposée par une entreprise
locale qui permet à ses clients de
distinguer autrement toutes les
richesses de la Corse grâce à un
hydravion un itinéraire d'une trentaine
de minutes au-dessus de l'eau et des
paysages et pousse sous plants comme
vous le voyez sur ces images de nos
partenaires de via télépaser encore
c'est écouter à ce propos le témoignage
de Francine elle a 90 ans et elle s'est
vu offrir l'expérience pour son
anniversaire
formidable on a un guide un pilote qui
nous renseigne bien on a tout vu Bastia
sous un autre angle voilà c'est très
bien voilà un témoignage recueilli par
Angel ericciardi de via télépasée la
chaîne TNT de Corse restons dans les
airs pour terminer cette édition avec
ses très belles images fournies par nos
confrères de la Dépêche du Midi du Salin
de Gruissan sur 400 hectares on peut y
contempler ces eaux rosés éblouissantes
un spectacle merveilleux pour les yeux
et le sel de nos plats bien sûr voilà
c'est la fin de ce grand JT des
territoires merci d'avoir suivi cette
édition on se retrouve très vite pour
une prochaine édition au revoir à tous
[Musique]